i chose paul mitchell the school of st
louis because i visited other schools
and when i was at them i just felt like
the energy level
wasn't the same it wasn't as elevated as
it is here
when i came here it just felt right
everybody looked great everybody had
such a great attitude
the facility was really clean and just
so much more advanced
technology can truly enhance your
education
when we brought in chromebooks and we
started using the smart tvs we really
tapped into
the 21st century learner
being a student of paul mitchell is
great because the learning leaders are
there
to guide you in the right direction they
give you the opportunity
to make decisions on your own they
accept you for who you are
and they're always welcome and honest
and open
we have encouraged our guests to host
google reviews so far to date have over
100 reviews with an average rating of
4.5 stars
i like that this isn't just for hair and
beauty but it's also a business college
you can learn hair you can brush that
you can tease that you can learn
all of that but to do business that's
something that really takes
a whole different level of education
whether we're in the classroom or at the
color bar we're always having a great
time at paul mitchell the school of st
louis
being a student paul mitchell gives you
a lot of opportunity for when you're
ready to get out into the real world
thank you for taking a sneak peek of our
campus and we can't wait for you to come
and see what a paul mitchell education
can do for you
and we're back at the u.s championship
in u.s women's and
uh to play off that hair commercial it
looks like
we are in trouble with the melakina
in the uh most stylish game of the us
women's championship today
sure for sure uh we had they
the players had reached this position
and white's pawn structure on c3
d4 appears to be undermined by the pawn
on b4
however this move d5 totally
cemented white's advantage he's ahead of
pawn
and after the move knight e5
uh pardon me i meant to i meant to point
out the threat that knight
e5 threatens knight f3
check and wins an exchange wins the rook
for a knight
but this move f2 f4 comes with tempo
the queen on f1 is ideal defending the
square f3
and it's a route from this point onwards
knight d7
see three takes b4 two pawns up
for white a5 queen b5 and just a
beautiful bishop and pins everywhere
this game is going to be over shortly
absolutely victory for for purple or for
tata
who's actually number three ranked in
the tournament and a serious contender
here
and also in the women's championship we
have former champion
um i am camilla behind skyki and
she is with grandmaster maurice ashley
thank you jen uh with i am as you said
camila begins
camilla thanks for joining us uh you had
a tough game today uh
this move that sabina played knight
takes f7 was
was really a tough move and you were
saying that there are reasons why such a
mistake will be made by a player
of your caliber uh you know it's just
i left too little time honestly and what
happens quite often
you make a mistake not in time trouble
itself but approaching time trouble
you kind of get nervous about it every
time so and uh
hari with some move and uh i played rook
ft and i was on general ground semester
and i saw
well it doesn't work so well oh i indeed
did not work out
when you saw the move that you knew you
were in trouble right away when you saw
knight of seven knight on the board
of course i did i mean so because it's
just that
all good squares belong to white
and so you can uh maybe i'm so you can
find the famous sort of prolonged time
so but uh i don't think you can really
defend successfully after that
it's just too many weaknesses indeed she
played very accurate moves after that
according to
the computer so camilla after a round
like this i mean you play in a lot of
u.s
women's championships after a bad round
what do you do to come back and and have
a good result okay first of all i try to
get a good sleep which i didn't manage
yet i'm sorry to say but i mean so but
it's always hard for me to get into
the groove after uh well i'm
so after family life i mean so it's uh
just it's a whole new schedule is
completely different i mean so and i
still cannot get used to it quite yet
so i'll try to get a good sleep sleep is
sleep is first and then and then after
that you know what do you do you do
tactics do you just review the games as
usual
anything else it's pretty much as usual
i mean so but uh as i said i'm so you
have to be well arrested
yeah indeed well thank you so much
camilla for uh
gracing us with your presents we wish
you luck in the rest of the
championships thank you maurice
camilla against after a difficult first
game
and uh she'll bounce back she'll get
some rest
back to you jen and yes absolutely by
the way jen for myself i found that if i
don't sleep
i have big big issues in the tournament
but when i'm sleeping well
even am i having a bad result i usually
do bounce back
but sleep is vital how about for
commentary
did you get your eight hours i need i
need my sleeve i'm just still recovering
from the jet bike but yeah
i brought i brought up a very important
game ray robson saint louis
local hero is playing against sergey
and rey has built up a very
nice promising attack against
sergey's king let's go back a few moves
just to review how the players got here
they're playing really quickly it seems
i wonder if one of the players
one of the players looks to be in a bit
of time pressure yeah so let's get yeah
so uh we got to this position we had
showed it
this capture rook d7 as expected queen
h4
that looks a little strange i wanted the
queen closer to the king
queen h4 ray jumped on that move with
queen
a five let's get to the game because
they're playing extremely quickly
they're about to make through four years
so where are we at now so this is where
i i left it and let's just see we've got
several more moves in
queen b5 happened rook gc6
queen a6
ah where is it was it the fifth game
there it is there we go okay and now
we've got work take c7
and so we've got seven work
and this is the current position we have
on the board with
um sergey having about 30 seconds and
ray robson with a minute and a half
this is looking like like game over here
this is dead that one looks like it's a
it's made in a few moves right
no i just take the rook if it's not made
but if this
position is on is right if we play king
b6 and what if you go the other way to d
yeah ooh oh the other way to d8 sorry
sorry
no i mean either way b6 is hanging with
check
so king d8 i was just going to take this
bomb with check
and rey is
winning i mean just flat in the game all
right so where
so where did this all go wrong for
sergey i guess it happened
let's well let's let's uh hold up and
watch the game conclude
it doesn't look like king d6 queen takes
b6 check occurred
and now we are on move 39. so it might
be one of these things where sergey
plays a few more moves he played king to
d7
okay so we have seen this this queen
takes b6 so we're up to date with the
players
king d7 has been played and
rey is definitely
winning ray looking happy he actually
just played a rook to d1 jack
rook it seems like he's got this all
and the game is over and we have our
first decisive result in the u.s chess
championship with ray robson young blood
from st
louis winning and you know we always
said from the beginning that it's going
to be interesting to see
who really charges out of the gate here
absolutely it looks like it's ray
ray one of the youngest players here in
the field right the second youngest i
believe after
afternoon right so um fantastic
performance so what went wrong there
let's back up a couple moves um we we
will expect to get ray um
down here to talk about it as well if
you if you have any specific questions
for him
you know you might want to give us a
head up at um us chess champs and
twitter
and we might be able to get them in
sometime so my first impression was this
move queen h4
basically leaving the king
that really whoa you're not supposed to
do that and this move queen a5
very powerful move threatening queen c7
check as well as
to be able to win this pawn on c5 oops i
beg your pardon went too fast there
uh rook c8 was the answer to queen a5
sometimes i hit the wrong controls queen
takes
queen g5 and this nice move right here
a4 beginning to soften up the queen side
with the threat of a4a5 so this is a
dual purpose move on the one hand you
get out out of the back ranked mate
on the other hand you're ready to play
a5 and finally
white is ready to double on the seventh
rank
which is we know is truly devastating
c5 that wasn't really helpful move
either queen a5
rook c6 queen a6
and maybe he forgot about rook takes out
c7
when sergey went into this whole
variation i'm sure he expected that he
would
be able to play rook takes c7 then he
would be able to recapture at the rook
he forgot
48 maybe in the game precisely well well
just uh just lovely we thought that that
was going to be an advantage for ray but
we sure didn't think that it was going
to finish
uh finished quite like that or so
quickly snap crackle pop right yeah yeah
yeah well i i suspect it was that
running for the fisher prize
there you go i suspect it was that one
error that's how
how how good these guys play that you
can't allow yourself even
the slide to slip they're so good
they will make you pay they will win a
game if you give them the opportunity
and ray looked really good and you think
that was with queen h4
yeah my first impression is like whoa
whoa
that was wrong maybe ray will correct me
but i think queen h4 really
was a nice surprise for him and we do
have
a grandmaster ray robson in studio with
maurice ashley
indeed with our first victor on the male
side of
the championships grand master ray
robson
local boy so i'm sure the local heroes
are quite happy about that now you go to
university not far from here ray
congratulations on your game thank you
ray this game looked like you were
giving him the squeeze for a while it
didn't look like you had
that much coming out of the opening and
then all of a sudden bam
you were mating him his king was running
on the board tell us what happened
yeah um well he played the petrov which
is
known to be a pretty solid opening but
we got an interesting position i thought
y was supposed to be better in this line
but during the game it wasn't really
clear to me if i was
actually better and i think at some
point he probably should have tried to
force the issue
with my g5 pawn thing something like h6
just to see
what i'm going to do if i'm going to
take or or not because
i think leaving the pawn there is to my
advantage and then
perhaps he missed this idea rook h3 to
rook b3
swinging my rook to the queen side and
i think i mean i felt like i had the
initiative there but
still it was very complicated and i
sacrificed the pawn
just to get the seventh rank with my
rook and it looked very good
during the game but i'm not sure if it
was actually that much better for me if
i just had
very very good compensation well all
that initiative
is is that something that you feel is
the right way to play when you're in
with the white pieces just go for it
i've seen you do it before sacrifice
upon
just maybe make them really
uncomfortable you know it's really
stating your intentions
yeah well especially for me i think
that's just naturally my style kind of
so um
for me as an e4 player just to play
with the initiative play aggressively as
much as possible
and you know sergey is a very solid
player so
maybe the kind of complications or where
he has to defend isn't exactly what he
he wanted in this game indeed well
you're in
first place at the moment i mean of
course it's only the first the first
around we did see a quick draw and we're
getting opinions on this we saw a quick
draw in the komski
guerrero game like 15 moves repetition
what are your thoughts about games like
that um
i i'm not really sure how to evaluate
the position it looked okay for black so
i mean i can understand why
if grav didn't see anything you know
maybe he just
thought it's uh you know it's
it's uh reasonable just to take a draw
there but
um yeah normally i'd like to see more
fighting games but
also they're you know one number one
number three seat i think so
maybe two depends on number one system
you use so
maybe the the fight for first was a
little bit too early for them just
they just wanted to get adjusted and
settled into the tournament indeed
you're going to
school still i imagine how are you
balancing school with
playing in the us chess oh it's tough
but
um fortunately i basically finished by
right now
just before the tournament and uh the
whole
webster university has been very very
supportive the staff
the provost president been very
supportive of
the chess team and all of our players
and me
and um yeah with that support i think
it's been able to make make this
possible for me i heard a stat is this
really your seventh u.s championship
i think so because i played in all the
ones that have been in st
louis and i played in one in 2007. so
that's
that's indeed seven incredible how old
are you 19 yeah
absolutely mind-blowing uh i guess one
final thought on the youngest player in
the event
uh on the women's side uh young sharitha
what was it like being that young and
playing in the u.s championship what
advice would you have for her and her
family
um for me it was a bit intimidating but
uh i think well i mean she has her
rating and she deserves it and she
deserves a place in this tournament i
mean she's earned it so um
she should just be confident not be
afraid of anyone
and um all she can do is play the best
that she can
and hopefully the results will be good
for her indeed i'm sure she'll see many
more of these events as well
grandmaster ray robinson congratulations
on your game best of luck in the rest of
the tournament thank you
back to you jen and yes thank you
maurice wow so seven already
and you know the all-time leader joel
benjamin only has 26
only 26. only 26 but seven that means
that ray could catch him
before he's 40. well this is what i'm
struggling with
ray is the second youngest player in the
field and have played
seven events he's a veteran for crying
out loud so
that's really remarkable he must have
been one of the youngest
uh u.s champ u.s participants
as well but that is pretty awesome
sometimes
you have a breakthrough as a junior and
you
you get invited and win so it's
impressive that he's played
consecutive u.s championships uh he's
always been in there
so very good for ray and again
that uh most tournament record is held
by joel benjamin grandmaster
who now lives in new jersey new yorker
and he's also
in the world chess hall of fame yes
definitely very very deserving
my generation like hey
my generation hall of famers okay
uh what other games would we like to go
to we've had quite a few decisive
results we are
expecting victoria to win her game
it's not that simple though it's rook
versus bishop
we have only one so we've only got two
games left in the championship we've got
that uh rook and game in a kobe and
naritsky and a game we haven't looked at
for a while actually for del lenderman
um the last fridell the us open champion
um they had that kind of english opening
uh c45 line and
i think uh lenderman's looking good here
if i've got the
the game right uh yeah it looks like
we've got
seems to be in a bit of trouble he must
have misplayed this english if
if i recall it shall we take a look at
the
the position yeah so lenderman seems
like he's going into a pawn up end game
here
you know maybe we're working on getting
it up we see them meeting them here on
the webcam
yes is there yeah
and everyone's looking good yeah with
the players from this championship
already in the wall behind them that's
really cool that's
that's how they do things here in the st
louis chess club everything is
really just so professionally done they
take their headshots the next day
they're framed and on the wall exactly
and you know that's why
we're we're glad to be here the
organization is just fantastic
in so many ways and the players had
reached this position
and nothing seems to be wrong
it's pretty okay i actually i think i
still favor white
slightly but something started to go
wrong
about these parts d5
and right there
josh must have overlooked a tactic
oh my gosh he overlooked the simplest
tactic in the world
rook takes e4 which is rook takes c3
check
dark i mean sometimes you're calculating
many many moves deep and then
you know it's like missing a layup in
basketball you could dunk it
in three different ways and then you
missed the layup well that was also a
move 40 it seemed so
maybe that was part of the issue as well
so what happened here was he played
he dropped back with his king and he
ended up a pawn down
with a dominant knight good rook and an
extra
pawn so lenderman definitely winning e3
check and have we got uh the position
yeah i think we think maurice has
something to share so basically he just
played he just blundered when he played
that 39th move with it exactly
it's just an oversight oh that's a shame
indeed so he
i guess he was just looking he was just
looking at lines like rook takes e4 work
takes before king takes
it for him right without looking at all
the different move orders
and clearly must have been something
related to time pressure as well
and we have just seen the move king d3
by josh
but now all of these pawns on the king
side are falling rook takes f4
by lenderman that's a second pawn
usually
a pawn and a half i don't know how you
get the half
but upon and a half are decisive in
grand master games two pawns
is two too many and here it looks like
even a third pawn is
is going to so i don't think josh is
going to
be around and drag this one out he's
definitely
losing well we so we might have a more
decisive date
in the championship than we thought we
would right we've already got a win
there by rey
and um still a cobia narrative ski is in
the air
do you want to take it or draw but yes
biology not
not oh yes okay now we've got um a much
more simplified position than we saw
last time
um with a rook in two years
versus rick and pawn yeah right when we
left it
i thought it was a key moment several
moves back
um i had mentioned
this position um pardon me
it was this position check and daniel
had to
had to choose very carefully either king
e7
or king g7 he did choose for king g7
and after all of these very forcing
looking moves
in the end he managed to get to a
position
where
it's two versus one very active black
king
this game should be a draw in my opinion
it's probably even in that
what we would call a table base but i do
believe
that daniel will will hold the position
and that this game will be drawn all
right
so two likely decisive results today
in the us chess championship let's uh
take a look at
our young sharitha swan and see how
she's doing over
in the women's okay when we had left
that game we
really thought that it was pretty
over we had seen we'll go back a few
moves maurice had explained that
white victoria had won black's queen
and they reached this position and
now at this moment uh two pawns for the
bishop that's usually
great compensation especially as this
bishop
is going to get anchored the problem is
she's not going to be able to save one
of her queenside pawns
that's why i thought victoria was going
to win this game
but i am not sure what is going
on at the moment and this is the
position
and well again i think that the
rook just is so
much stronger in these positions with
pawns on both planks
that yeah i like white's chances of
winning i would be rather surprised
if victoria didn't win this game
but it's by no more one of those uh one
of those queen taipons are going to fall
and then
exactly and then an aeropon is going to
be so much more powerful
right so yeah i would i would agree with
that even though right now
glass got material compensation it's not
going to last
exactly that's why we like to work so
much in the endgame
yeah the rook much more powerful than
the bishop now
if the queenside ponds were removed
completely all of those pawns were off
the board
and it was one versus three we would say
oh i like black's chances
right but the whole difference is is
that the bishop to hold on to the pawns
right
if there were that would be a different
story but totally if you play
if you play b5 then we go after the a
pawn with rook a8
and exactly it's gone if you try to move
the a pawn
then we like for instance a5
exactly going behind those pawns and you
just can't defend them
exactly and once white wins one of the
queen side pawns
then she will have a she will generate a
passer herself
and likely the rook would force the win
of the bishop
that's right exactly and we've we've got
some thoughts
from uh grandmaster ashley
on one of the most exciting games around
indeed i wanted to dig a little deeper
into this position jen
so that i could really suck some of the
juice out of it it was really a fine
win by grand master ray robson but
the truth is he may not have won this
game if his opponent had found
a key defensive move yeah as you had
mentioned you didn't like this move
queen h4
it turned on that black was still
hanging on by his
fingernails if in this position instead
of playing queen to g5
he had played this funky move rook to e6
this move is tricky obviously rook takes
rick's not playable because of the back
rank
the mate that we've been seeing all this
time and this would have disrupted
white's flow also
the reality is white can't play that
great move queen before anymore
because of the fact that the queen is
defending
laterally so this was the critical
moment he needed to find
a good defensive move actually it's not
even his only one but it's the most
interesting of all of them instead of
doing that he played the move queen to
g5
and this is a howler the computer goes
crazy immediately it's like this you're
done
see you tomorrow now after queen to b4
this pawn is under heavy pressure and
there's no easy defense anymore
the main reason being if you try to
bring your queen over to this side
which he might have thought that he
could do in fact in this position
he runs into this nasty line queen f4
check king over and then kaboom
queen into c7 and that's all she wrote
you can't touch the queen because
either rook will be fighting for the
background checkmate in that position
this gives me a bad recollection of what
happened to me just recently in the last
game i played uh
just like this a queen landed in front
of me so
bad memories let's get rid of this
position real quick so now
queen of b4 threatening here he was
forced to play b6
and then this super cool move a4
or a3 by the way both moves do the job
just a great move stop all the back rank
mates now
everything is super solid black is in
deep trouble
the variation here to look at is the
move queen to a5
again can i bring my queen over can i
get some help
all right uh no because bam two rooks
doubled
on the seventh rank you don't want to
see these guys queen takes queen would
not be possible
because of this mate that we all know
and love
on the seventh rank two rooks
checkmating
very nicely and once the rooks landed
all the threats are there now
black is in deep trouble a move like
queen to a6 trying to deal with the
rooks
but white has the ferocious queen for
fort check king over to a8
and now let's just start eating stuff
and end it all with queen to f7 check
give me that rook so ray just had him
completely under control
by the end a really dominant win by the
young
player and we hope to see more of these
kind of games
in the u.s championships back to you jen
and yaz that's right you got to love
that game and i heard a rumor that
uh if you get background cake mated you
got to do 200 push-ups
so and i think that that counts um
even maurice's loss from i don't know
months ago it still counts so
he's getting busy and so if he's a
little sweaty in his next segment you'll
know why
don't get backrank checkmated so it
wasn't queen h4 that was the howler it
was the move queen
g5 because that move rook e6
keeps the game going and that's very
nice i miss rook e6 too i must say
i just didn't i just focused on the move
queen h4 and i was thinking gosh queen
eight five didn't feel right
bring your queen away from the defense
because you just no you usually need um
all your defenders when
you're getting uh taken by all the major
pieces like that
right with major pieces just the major
pieces on the on the board uh
king position king safety is just so
critical
and that was a an instructor for those
of you who aren't as advanced and
making attacks uh that apon yes right
that's almost like another piece
it is it seems like it's very
minimalistic how you're gonna just
checkmate with a couple of rocks
right but ray was like oh the pawn
counts right and
uh a4a5 was a very serious uh
improvement in white's position getting
out of the back rank made as well
and it looks like we're about to have a
result also on another game that we
looked at earlier between uh
abrahamian amelikina we saw that um
tata's position loved kapu i mean sorry
alyssa's position with kapoot earlier
has anything changed
okay let's bring that game up on our
board it
it really did look like white was
completely dominating we saw
we had left the position just a few
moves ago somewhere around here we saw
this move queen b5
this came white was already two pawns to
the good
was cruising towards victory queen b5
knight f8
that's pawn number three by the way boy
those pawns
are really beginning to add up check
rook be a queen and whoa
another back rank uh issue and this is
the position that we currently have uh
any scary tactics by
perpetual check i see a line i think we
can just give up the uh
you can just give the rook up on e1 i
think maybe tata's idea here is that if
rook b8 rook b8
um check king h7 we can just play e7
because if queen d2 checked just king f3
that could be what's going on here
because of check king f3 and
you're threatening to queen exactly and
i don't and now if you check me in other
places now we can actually block with a
rook and
uh seems like eventually you're gonna
run out of checks here
we gotta be sure but because otherwise
we might get mated like
queen f2 chat king h5 g6 would be kind
of an
anonymous thing how many push-ups do we
need to do for that
no no no g6 g6 right away sorry
somehow though like with like rook g3 or
something i think what we could do
probably is just step back for a moment
king f2 how's this
as as an easy win
for white there are no tracks and it
looks pretty easy breezy
yeah exactly so what do you have to
worry about g6 made get your king on h5
g6 no
the one i was thinking about jen was
instead of taking the queen right away
could we mix it up with this move queen
here for
i i don't doubt that white's winning uh
but are there any tricks
around here what would you do
as blo as white would you go king g3
with the idea of moving your king to h4
or
would you see in well i see what you're
trying but so if i go king g3 you've got
the
extra option of playing like queen takes
e1
well yeah then i have to still go after
the question
i take c one checking that takes b8
although that's still losing
because we've got e7 and a6 a7 a8
yeah well you get all that that's over
that's overkill
but uh yeah no i was just i was just
looking at this
i guess it just doesn't matter i think
it's i think it's just
actually rather transpositional yeah
liking a three anyway
yeah and after king h7 this
uh your move e7 that looks
good enough just simply it's good enough
and uh there's no perpetual check
expecting the variation where g6 may
happen
right
yeah this looks like um it will be
another decisive game in the chat
and the women's championship we still
believe that and
uh yeah nice uh nice opening performance
um by some of our ladies um sabina and
tata both playing
playing well in their games yeah and
arena crush is still playing by the way
that game is not over i thought that one
would end but it seems that katarina is
is still hanging on not really hanging
on in the position so much as
hanging on and not resigning
a lost cause you're saying well it
doesn't look too good
that is true but i mean you can't blame
anyone for
it's part of the rules right you're
allowed to keep playing that's totally
ridiculous and you're down like two
rooks i mean
no don't know i i actually like playing
on so that everybody can understand
exactly exactly how the position was
going
it's kind of good for us as commentators
to get able to see
it get to a more advanced stage before
somebody resigns
we had left that game more or less
around these parts
and i thought that this was pretty
decisive
arena there's a couple of checks
but now black's king is perfectly safe
this was a very fine move getting behind
the pass pawn
making it as awkward as possible for
arena to win the game
queen f5 knight
king h7 and we have this position so
a big material advantage for arena an
exchange in pawn extra and
black is having to deal with this
past pawn this knight c5
the way i see it essentially what black
needs to do
is uh prepare herself for this pawn
advance either through rook h3
or some other method but
if white has any chances it's based upon
her getting her b pawn going and i don't
think that's realistic
neither yeah but it seems that this game
is going to go on as uh
nemkova tries to make a crush
proof yes well well do your best to give
your opponent as many problems as you
can
but in this position just the material
is
the decisive factor it's just too much
and let's see do we have i was thinking
that
daniel it's looking closer and closer
like a draw between mereditsky and var
we do have a couple moves in there so it
seems that black
we got king c2 c4 in since our last
since we last checked out back in
right not too much has changed there um
well we're certainly winding it down
josh is still playing against leonard
lenderman
that looks like a losing ending and i
think we've got a maybe a little bit of
action going on
in the knee game wow
okay sure enough let's have a look at
that
that is our 11th game of the event
okay so indeed victoria did
win one of queen
side pawns she did win one of black's
queen side pawns
but look what eswaran did she
she she can make a blockade with the
move bishop a4
oh let's just have a look maybe we were
we were too early in reading her
last rites indeed okay so we left it
more or less around these parts
we had kind of thought that once you win
the pawn
on the queen side the game's over but
the young lady found a very fine
idea of being able to blockade the
queen's side
with the move bishop a4 that's right
because the king on f6
is now close enough to that uh b-pawn so
that uh
rick takes a4 is not going to win the
the game right
right after b5 will be able to play
king to e7 and
just in time stopped up on from queening
right
yes it was a race but uh
that would be great to see uh
a tough defense here from her first ever
women's championship game
pretty impressive that was a nice
hidden defensive resource so
applause if she if she saves this game i
tell you
it's a real confidence booster your
first u.s championship
you're playing as black you had a bad
position
you pull it out you feel great now we
have a real theoretical
battle going on in zhenya versus tansky
with zaponski also showing her defensive
medal um this is a real classic we've
got going on here where
um anna i'm sorry irina has an extra
pawn
and she's got her work in front of it
right
so here if white were to push that pawn
an extra square
actually that would make the victory
even less likely
so that we're actually we're about to
get that game up on the board that
zenyuki game but this is an end game
which everyone really should know
because it comes up so frequently
rook and pawn end games represent
roughly speaking 50 percent
of all the types of endings that are
reached between experienced players
especially grand masters
and today's pro today's round was kind
of proved positive
of the popularity of rook endings
as we're seeing a number of them um
white
i thought sonia was really going to win
this game frankly i thought
she had a winning position she nursed it
nicely she ended up being an extra pawn
ahead
but not enough to convert and i think
this position
is more is going to be a draw i agree
because now if white were to play a
if white ever plays a7 she's actually
trapped her own rook there on a8
if it ever leaves rook takes a7 is going
to be played
exactly and that's the cool thing about
this position
that get that king on g7 actually helped
black
because it stops the rook from going to
those squares
you know like h8 and trying to get a
little score in
right yep or if if the king were to push
forward
same issue there would be a rookie 8
shack for instance if the king were in
e5 theoretically
exactly so actually king g7 tucked away
and to the side is unlike most end games
that's where you want your kin usually
you want your king as a fighting pace in
the center
precisely this is an exception and
that's why it's one of the cooler end
games
and it's also the reason why we're not
going to see zenyuk play a7
if she has any shot in this position she
has to figure out a way
to get her king over to the side but the
problem with that
is that then the g pawn would hang and
that might make the withdrawal even
easier
exactly so i think this one is going to
be a draw shortly actually
right one of the things that white can
can try
let's say we're just going to move our
rook we can bring our king
all the way over to the the queen side
right but we can't find any shelter for
the king
in other words if we could get the king
here to b7
we could then move our rook and promote
our pawn
but black is not going to allow that and
it is a draw and that's the thing that's
why i was saying
if you try doing the same thing with the
pawn on a6 then the king maybe could
tuck in the a7
right but the problem with that is then
i'd capture on g4 and then come back
and i've got a past f-bomb by the time
you're moving your king to a7
and so they have agreed to draw yeah
then you didn't see any way to make
progress in that game
surely a little bit disappointed that
she didn't squeeze more out of that but
also
if you told her before the game should
be good probably not hugely
disappointing she has the white pieces
but also against
an opponent that's been so tough for her
right having lost six games this
this game almost feels like a loss if
you will because he did have what looked
like a very promising
likely winning position at some moment
in the game
and to spoil it and to make a draw feels
deflating on the other hand for anna
i don't know how she feels her best
customer
has not paid the bill i didn't give her
the point
and on the other hand she must feel
relieved that she
escaped i think she probably feels
pretty good because
you know she anna's not a as active as
some of the other players this year
and she's always got these great
fighting spirit these amazing defensive
skills she's never really been the
opening person
so i think you know she got a bad
opening and you know she fought her way
out of it that's kind of her
the way she the way she plays every year
she she plays these
long fighting games and she pulls half
points and full points
out where people wouldn't expect them
and it's another example of it exactly
she
just battles all the time she doesn't
give you
anything and like you say her openings
naughty naughty dan daniel her husband
who's the chess grandmaster should be
working with her a little bit better
to sharpen up her openings a bit but
normally speaking when she gets these
middle games she's just a
good hard fighter she doesn't give you
anything and
and that's why she's he gets all the
questions the middle game and the end
game and the fighting spirit and her
husband gets all
the blame for the openings that's sounds
pretty fair
that's right that's right
typical typical uh we don't have yet
uh melakina uh abraham
is still uh don't have an actual result
but um that's so we so we've got only a
couple games still going on
we've got a knees game against the
suaren in the women's championship
we've got abrahamian malaquina and then
cover crush
and accurate narratives yeah and linda
but a lot of those games we feel we
were pretty confident in what directing
they're going exactly
i do feel that lindemann is going to win
this game against josh friedl i
don't know if lenderman played it so
well it looked like he was
pretty convincingly winning
he still is he should still win though
great let me see arenas game let me just
pull arena's game up on our scoreboard
once more
um
i was thinking that okay so white has
managed to advance her pawn
to b4 she is hoping to create
some counter chances but it takes so
many tempe for her to do this i'm
i'm quite sure that she's not gonna have
the time i'm thinking
rook e2 in case of knight d6
queen um c2
threatening queen takes b2 mate this
should be winning
this should be winning wait so what
about ig three was there something there
sorry uh did they get until running was
an f5 right
yeah so in this position
uh i played you played rookie two oh i'm
sorry
rook e2 yes rookie to knight g3
fork my icc blitz rating just went down
yeah that's why knights are so annoying
don't resign when you still have a night
left on the board
and we do have a four-time u.s women's
chess champion
anna zatonski and she is with
grandmaster maurice ashley after
pulling out a draw in her first round
battle
indeed i guess you don't get to become a
four-time champion
unless you know how to fight and you
indeed had to fight
in this game anna it looked bad for you
at one point what were your thoughts
when you looked at the position
thinking i beat this woman six times
before what's happening now
yeah it's good to know that you should
tell me during the game that i beat you
six times yeah i didn't know that
um okay i was upset and i thought that
so i should
train more before the us championship
and i had to play one more tournament
i didn't play chess over one year so i
mean like a nine round tournament
so my last tournament was u.s
championships and
during the game i was thinking oh my god
why i didn't play and it's like strong
open yeah
so i think it's it's difficult yeah i
know i played like
on weekends but it's it's difficult uh
not to play chess and then play such
a strong tournament and right away i had
to
win but i didn't so but eventually draw
was a good result since my position
wasn't
very promising combining life as a mom
and and a chess player uh you also have
a husband who's a
grandmaster as well uh the the our
hosts were saying that it's his fault
why you got a poor opening
no no no it's not his fault it's not his
fault definitely
he's a very good coach but it's not his
fault yeah so this move g5 when you
played it in the opening it it just
seemed like
wow that that that signaled to us that
something must have gone wrong
but i didn't know what to do my opponent
on d5 was canon and
um i just my time was running and i just
couldn't find
anything better when you were in this
situation you're thinking round one my
position's terrible
how do you get the ghosts out of your
mind that it's like i could be losing
the first round and this could be just
an awful tournament
do you ever get thoughts like that
not really i'm playing chess for many
many years and of course i just try to
calculate variation and
i try hard to to play very good chess so
i didn't have the thoughts
excellent keeping your head focused on
the game well now that you've
gotten the draw as black are you feeling
good moving forward you still have eight
strong rounds to go okay i hope i will
play better in next eight rounds and
of course i was down upon and
i'm not quite happy because the last one
hour we
one hour or just an hour we're just
moving pieces without any purpose and
already knew it was a draw
so um and
now i may be a little bit upset
the draw is not very good result but
okay we will see we have eight more
rounds and
uh i hope i will play better in the rest
of
the us chain we hope so too yeah thank
you
good luck in the rest of the games
thanks four-time champion
anna zatonski in good spirits after the
draw maybe she's just angry i wouldn't
want to be the one to play right next
round
back to you jen and yes uh anna's angry
wait a minute
wait a minute no but i understand her
point when the game
and you know it's a theoretical draw and
you you feel that you've achieved the
draw
and yet your opponent is just keep
pushing the pieces right around and
around
uh sometimes you just feel like like
what are you doing don't you
know any better so i can understand her
a little frustration
but a very mixed emotional game in the
sense that
you know she had her best opponent
and played poorly bad game and i just
looking at the game i saw josh friedl
extend his hand in resignation i believe
alexander lenderman has won
all right so two decisive games in the
us chess championship by two of our
younger players
alexander lenderman and also ray robson
absolutely
and plenty of decisive games in the
women's champion in fact uh
all of them so far so we've got
i'm sorry not all of them all the mixer
for zenyuk we've got um
looks like irida is going to win and it
also looks like tata is going to win and
we do have
an official win by sabina fueger rna
right
and let me just see
yeah lenderman i just pull up that final
position
that while we're waiting for our next
guest i think we're gonna go to my arena
zenyuk
um i wanted to remind everyone who might
be within striking distance of st
louis that we do have two amazing shows
opening at the world chess hall of fame
um tonight actually so as soon as this
broadcast is over we're gonna head over
there
for a glass of wine and some art
beautiful one of them is
cajun kaino cage of course the famous
composer and kaino that los angeles
artist i was referring to
earlier who likes to do things like make
candles into chess pieces
right and uh thumbs up right the hands
the hands
test that that and we've also got
strategy by design games by michael
graves
and that's a really cool one because he
designed a chess set that became a
really popular
board right so kind of like designing
sets for target and things like that
so that makes our game more popular of
course
of course of course and the exhibits are
just so beautifully presented over the
hall of fame for those of you who do
visit st louis
do make an effort because it's really
really nice we're
we're very proud of the hall of fame
exactly
really you gotta check it out and we do
have irina zenyuk and she's with
grandmaster maurice ashley
indeed after a long and difficult game
we have irina zenyak
first of all thanks for coming on the
show now we know
you lost six times to her so that was
something you wanted to break
at least that streak to stop and then
you had a pretty promising looking
position
although it wasn't so easy to break
through what were your thoughts when you
had
a really nice game and pounding her pawn
on d5
i um my goal was to play a solid game
that was uh having white pieces was
really helpful so achieving such a
really
pressing solid position against anna it
felt great and i felt like i was
close to gaining decisive advantage at
some point but it slipped away and
uh probably haven't played precisely the
end game but i thought overall it was a
good game
well she's she's tricky i mean she's
such an experienced player
she's she's been playing but for so many
years
do you feel like she was just a
difficult opponent for you because of
her style
or or maybe just her strength i think
it's
kind of it's both also like growing up
in ukraine
um she's also from ukraine and me being
like she's like maybe 10 years older
than me or something like that
me being a little girl watching on apply
for olympic team she was like my hero so
that also
i'm not sure if that helped or hurt but
she obviously she's very very strong
player and very experienced as you said
and her style is very solid so
both were um against i guess uh
hurting the game i guess for me so so
what do you feel now you've you've
gotten the draw it was a fighting draw
it wasn't something you just gave her or
she gave you
how are your spirits uh having such a
result right now um
i'm pretty happy with the game as i said
i haven't played chess since
a serious tournament since december so
it's good good to be back
it's good to play some good chess and
i'm just looking forward for the next
eight rounds
great attitude before i let you go i
know you've just finished your phd
degree and your new job tell us about
that oh yeah i completed my phd
after four and a half years at carnegie
mellon university in mechanical
engineering
studying renewable energy and now i'm at
berkeley national lab
doing a postdoc fellowship and i think
in a year i'll be
joining one of the university to become
a tenure track professor
fantastic well congratulations on that
thank you i can see why you might be a
little busy not playing too much
chess yeah yes your championship is
really
important for me and i really put up
some time to uh
to prepare for this so i'm really
excited to be here fantastic well good
luck in the rest of the event
thank you irina zenyak after a tough
game and uh
i think you'll see some more good games
from her later in the tournament
back to you jen and yes thank you
exceptional talent what an academic yeah
a phd already and fast-tracked the
professor and fuel cutting edge
technology and feel sensitive awesome
have a great career and be playing in
the women's championship as well so how
sweet it is pretty inspiring story there
and we've got a
i think we've got alexander lenderman
and josh ferdell set up to uh talk to us
a little bit about their game
um kind of interesting in that it was
decided by a blunder near time control
and
that's something that everybody can
relate to back on of course of course
it's happened to everybody making
mistakes in time pressure
everybody who has any experience in
tournament chess
the proverbial last move blunder of the
time control
was the decisive factor in this game and
this was just the final position of
alex slenderman's game and the problem
from white's point of view
is that he really has no way of
preventing
king d3 captures the pawn on c4
the king would drop back to the b5
square
that pawn would be captured on a5 and
then it would be simply
two pawns against the bishop in a knight
and it's just not a contest so
josh recognizing that the situations
lost
gave it up
and we've got grandmaster maurice ashley
with our latest guest
and our latest winner still in
contention for the fisher prize
alex lenderman indeed uh congratulations
alex first of all and winning your game
thank you so alex this position looked
very solid for a long time
and then all of a sudden it was over
what happened
well basically my opponent blundered an
idea d64 rook 64 rook takes c3
in mutual time pressure and that was
kind of the end of the game but
otherwise it should be roughly equal so
this
time pressure we know it makes fools of
us all it was just that simple he
did he have anything to say after the
game about about why he missed this
saying the time pressure was the real
reason well the probably the main reason
that happened was because
uh josh was better the whole game i
thought
he was pressing a little bit it was much
more pleasant for him to play he had a
time advantage
and then he somehow didn't find the
right plan and lost the threat a little
bit
and then he even had a little bit less
time and he had to find something he was
looking for something and
you know when that happens oftentimes
mistakes occur
indeed that's a very good point about
you start chasing the ghost of the
advantage
that you once had and now you have to
play a position that may just be equal
or even worse and that's really hard to
do
right or not necessarily even uh looking
for an advantage but just like
shifting the mindset and looking for
defensive moves all of a sudden
it could be a little bit tough
especially with lower time
i know that's not easy how do you do it
you know facing a position where you
knew you
should have been doing well and now
suddenly it's not doing so well
how do you adjust the mindset as you
call it i just try to play one move at a
time but i know it's not
easy at all it's difficult for me indeed
so
winning the first round you've been in
the u.s championship before you were
here two years ago
as a matter of fact did you win your
first round then as well yes
you did so you got off to a good start
how's it feeling uh little deja vu
uh well i don't want to look at it that
way it's a separate tournament
different players everything's different
this game was completely different
in two years ago i won a game against
ray robson where i had an advantage out
of the opening
and then i barely won after that because
ray kept defending very well
it almost slipped away from me whereas
here i felt like i really thought i
might lose this game because
i was getting out of play i was behind
on time it was a position i wasn't very
comfortable with
but you know i guess i was very
fortunate with this game well
fortune goes to the strong as they say
last question for you what's your view
of the championship itself being back in
st
louis after a one-year break uh how are
you feeling being
back in in the st louis chess club oh
it's a wonderful tournament
it's a great opportunity to play here
i'm blessed with opportunity to play
here
indeed well congratulations and best of
luck in the rest of the tournament thank
you
with grand master alex lenderman still
in contention for that
64 thousand dollar fisher prize we'll
see how that goes
later in the tournament back to you jen
and yaz
thank you and some great points there
about blundering um
we all want to cut down on our blunders
right and it even happens at the very
highest level
right well one of the things that alex
is talking about is
objectivity and he's a very objective
player at the board
he is assessing his chances
realistically he's not
you know thinking i'm winning i'm
winning i'm winning and all the time
but playing the percentages if you will
on the other hand in terms of that
mindset
changing from oh boy i've been defending
now i'm on the attack let me play to win
the players that i've really admired was
anatoly karpov and gary
kasparov those are players who always
felt that they were winning they were
not
really that objective they were trying
to win
and they were always searching for their
opportunity today
lenderman was presented with his
opportunity he was ready to strike and
he did it very well so
that's just nice then when it happens
and okay i have brought on our screen by
the way the game
uh the remaining game between in the u.s
championship varusia nakobian
on the left playing the white side
daniel naraditsky
upon behind and yet
an equal ending as var very well knows
himself
and although he's a pawn up and he's
hoping for a miracle
i don't think daniel's going to blunder
this one
yeah this looks like it's going to be um
another draw in the championship
absolutely yeah so two players leading
then we would have if this game is a
draw right we'd have lenderman
and we'd have rey so right
and uh for the women i'm still not sure
what's happening in the game between
victoria
that game is still ongoing as well yeah
that's probably the one
the game that we're really not exactly
sure it's kind of confusing we've got
three games still going on oh i should
mention that
has officially defeated alicia melakina
so we're going to hear from
one or both of them uh shortly here
so we have three winners in the world
well not not irena yet so just two so
far i'm sorry
okay okay so i still looking at a draw
and and let me bring up the game of
victoria because that game really is a
confusing one
i thought that victoria was well on her
way to victory
now i'm less sure let's just say
wow wild position so in this position
the last few moves have been
here she did find that bishop a4
idea by the way and the players have
reached this
and now the question is what would
happen after a4
what do you think jen we got to go down
with the check right
this check make sense yeah king drops
back
you take the pawn what else otherwise a5
and away you go
b5 and what are we going to do
something why do we play a3 here
tough one tough call not sure myself i
was thinking that you might want to
bring your king in
or you might want to push your jeep on
okay
after a36 you're just coming after the
pawn but i was thinking let's see
you want to get your bishop back because
you don't want to deal with b7 right
yes this is a now you're
you're losing your bishop and i think
that's all she wrote actually yeah
i guess something like this
is more or less the way the game's going
to unfold
but i think the rook is just going to be
too powerful uh
the pawns are not enough for black here
and the rook just simply wins
so instead after rookie five you know
instead of a4 it looked like um
the game didn't go like that um she
played rookie five instead and then we
had a
king age five champion
no she played pardon me
e5 rook e5 okay
so the idea for victoria she wants to
play king g4
and not have to suffer a bishop e2 check
and after rookie five how did kh-5 so
preventing that idea of king g4 as you
mentioned
and so now a4 was no longer having
pressure on the bishop on c4
it's on the menu so perhaps this is
working five we'll have to
puzzle that out after we hear from
our latest winner in the u.s women's
championship lovely
we've got tatev abrahamian with grand
master
maurice ashley thanks jen with tatev
abrahamian first of all congratulations
on your game thank you
the game was wild i mean it looked like
a
solid game for quite some time not many
exchanges just one pair of pawns
and then suddenly you played this move
g4
seemingly compromising your king again
she still looked fine and then all of a
sudden you had this big advantage
what happened uh well i thought knight
f4 was a bad move once i got her
or at least once i'm threatening her
light square bishop then her position is
going to collapse too because her light
squares are really weak
so i think if she wants men bishop just
takes some slightly worse i wasn't sure
what to do
indeed and then you just got an
overwhelming position i mean by by the
end it looked like you were dominating
but you still said it seems like you
made a couple of mistakes yeah
i forgot that um where i allowed 96
house 24
completely forgotten i don't think she
has a perpetual but at least she can
take a couple of puns
and i had the same thing happen last
year i had a winning position i
blundered again so
it's a first-round thing hopefully is it
jitters in the first round we've seen
we've seen some cagey chests by players
in the first round is that a normal
strategy in the first round of a big
tournament like this to
maybe just have to get warmed up i don't
think a strategy is just
the first round it's kind of rusty so
trying to get into it
have you been playing a lot of chess
lately and we know first of all
congratulations on getting your third
international masters norm
uh that's quite an achievement uh have
you been playing a lot of chess lately
yeah i have been i've been having a lot
of good results but my
last tournament was a disaster so i
think i'm still a little
shaken up by it so i'm trying to be a
little more careful with
still making wonders so it's so good
okay well we
can clean those up uh pretty quickly
what else are you doing other than
chassis full-time chests now or
i'm also teaching but i mean i'm pretty
much just think chess distinctions
immersed in it you you're you've been
victorious here
uh we saw a couple of victories on the
women's side so far as well
but on the men's side quite a few draws
there were a couple of victories but
particularly one draw between
the top two players in the tournament
you may have noticed they were out of
there in
15 moves or so uh what are your thoughts
on that kind of draw
i mean i don't know i i just feel like
the first round one and two are playing
i thought it was going to be such a big
game it's kind of like the
anand carlson the first round game and
everyone's made such a big deal and then
they just drew so fast it's kind of
anticlimactic i guess
indeed well you won your game are you
still in contention going forward
do you do you feel like anything a win
to your sales when you win the first
game what do you think it's like first
and done what do you mean i mean do you
feel like the first game is a big big
deal
in the tournament to win it or is it
like it's it's done now
it's history and we just need to play
the next game i mean i mean it's nice to
win games because
in this tournament especially like you
need usually historically like you need
like large amount of points to win so
like every little point counts so it's
good to win final question you came in
uh second
your best result of the us championship
you came in second was it two years ago
uh maybe maybe three years ago
people are saying it's like a two horse
race but maybe it's a two and a half
horse race
that was one thing said i don't mean to
say you're half a horse but
but they're saying that that you're
you've been perennially the
the third best how do you break through
because these two just seem to
be cleaning up the championships nine
between them now how do you break
through with with those two powerhouses
in front of you
i don't know i don't think i haven't
figured out yet so maybe this year
okay if i figured i'll let you know
please do
oh best of luck in the rest of the
tournament
back to you jen and jazz uh certainly a
good start for the
third horse in the race
wow you upgraded her upgrade yeah two
from here
from a half a horse to a full horse
there we go so um
let's take a look at what happened in
nia swaron because uh we got a few moves
going in there it looked like
victoria did play the a4 idea um
even after blazing her work on e5
um and now we've got a situation where
when we had left it we had just able to
come to a2 so in your variation
the pawn wasn't able to get that far
advanced so that changes matter
right it gives it a little bit of a
twist because you can't easily play the
whole
rook a7 b7 thing right well well
essentially
the way victoria played at the la black
and extra tempo
she black managed to put her king on h5
so we do have this situation i'm
expecting the move rook takes a2 by the
way
but now thanks to the king being on h5
the g pawn is coming very
very fast and i think so
this is the position on the board and
now this is a position where
wow you you're
i'd be a little worried if i were
victoria here
she may have let her opponent get too
much
play with these pawns and
a dramatic shift late
this in this a great tempo king h5
because now g4 and h3 and g3 are
comments let's take a look at
the line so so takes a2 so taking
advantage of the fact that bishop a2
allows
b7 instead we expect a swarm to play g4
check and now after king h2 force
um g3 check right and then after king
well if king g1 for instance and does
you think h3 is bye bye
what do you think yes i do and even
worse
there's a nice variation here i believe
it's going to go king h3
how's this as a variation i took the
rook
you're trying to make a queen uh-oh
spaghettio wow i'm threatening mate in
one so we have a pawn you gotta show
that on the board
and then after king james checkmate oh
okay
sorry sure of course it's not a back
rank mate so you don't have to do 200
push-ups by the way thank god
okay i think this is like a diagonal one
so i think it's something with the
obliques
maybe burpees uh-oh that's even worse
obliques obliques
all right so that's where i think
uh victoria is missing what's happening
i like that tech mate a lot
that very nice after uh g3 check one
more time
one more look so king you're just saying
bishop takes a2
and now if b7 bishop c4 and then
you were looking at the variation with
king g2 now instead
and then c5 check is winning precisely
and same thing if we try to play um if
we go
back in that variation do we have any
other options
well we started with the move rook a2
right
yeah so we started with rook a2 which
pretty much is the only choice if we go
b7 that's not very helpful either
because
in this case black is also getting the
chance to play g4
check and these two pawns are winning
the game
well here yet here you're just gonna
have to go after it in a different way
instead of playing
bishop c4 you just play like bishop e4
with the idea of bishop f8
f5 clear so yeah that'll be awful
yeah so i'm just thinking that
i'm i'm sure rook takes a2
was victoria's intent and then when she
playing b7 she probably stopped here
not realizing oops do i have the
position wrong did i just do it wrong
no no because earlier you were talking
before exactly
i i was doing jewish for a check
immediately not bishop takes day two
thank you sorry yes because otherwise
they have kindy too of course
of course so once the pawn is on g3
now it's this mating net that suddenly
comes out of nowhere
that wins the game for black amazing
yeah i think it's a move order thing she
probably
forgot about this particular move order
that's right
and the other problem is if white
doesn't put her
king in this mating net if she
ends up going king g1 that's not helpful
either
because after h4 h2
black is going to force the win of a
rook
right so is there any way we can we can
make it to some exchange here
no let's see how well you
h2 is going to be mate so you've got to
kind of
leave your rook on um
the square no if you play
b7 i'll play h2 and i'll
only win the rook when i can also win
the pawn
and this is trivial of course
so hmm i think that victoria
has blown what we both thought was a big
advantage for
her wow what a beautiful uh variation
there so we do
do we have a move we have g4 in the
position
so oh so instead of um playing rick
takes a2
um we've got uh a move king h true
so victoria probably saw that and
decided to play king h2 instead and then
g4 anyway whoa wait a minute
no that would happen yeah is this
different now g
b7 pardon me um
the bishop is in an absolute pin
we can always queen and intake on b7
right but just a moment just a
moment no tricky trickies oh you're
saying i haven't
well i have made in one so you can't
queen yeah that's a pro
yeah i can't i can't do any trickies uh
here
so you just have to take on a1 and then
after bishop takes b7 we have that same
position where we're coming in with
g3 and bishop e4 and bishop f5 check
exactly or bishop f3 we kind of have our
choice of squares right well remember we
were talking about what if we were to
eliminate all the pawns on the queen
side
then it would be bishop versus rook but
three pawns versus one everybody would
want to be black well
remarkably enough we got that precise
and rick a5 check that doesn't help at
all
bishop d5 right rook a5 check bishop d5
and i now say like white just plays rook
c5 or something
yeah i think the black king is just
going to approach the d-pawn
you don't you you're under no obligation
to move these pawns
right until you're really good exactly
and until
you're ready for it but here you're
going after the d-pawn
so my goodness if s warren was to win in
this game
he'll be a sensational star 13 year old
in her debut
winning with black in round one wow
remarkable so definitely a stressful
moment for me
who perhaps just missed that i mean it's
not that hard to miss that
bishop c4 thing especially because she
might have just thought that she like
she was playing pretty well this game
mm-hmm other things were kind of going
in her direction
exactly exactly in fact it's a very
nice meeting net right very beautiful
good fine yasser and we've got
grandmaster maurice ashley
with uh something on our remaining game
from the championship
indeed i wanted to make a point because
i remember a story from
2003 that involved one of our players
that is varusa nacobian played in the
u.s championship
i remember the last round they saw 10
players
on the top board all within striking
distance of winning in fact there were
tie going into the last round everybody
was excited
about seeing that last round game and
last round games
five key games in the matchup and what
did we see
four of the games ended in quick draws
there was only one game that actually
went on and it was a game between
shabala of grand master shabbat who was
not here at this championship
and verouncobian they played
a long game and in the end shabbat won
and won the title
clear the organizer eric anderson was so
upset about the other draws
he did something unusual he gave five
thousand dollars
to shabala of anakobian for their
fighting spirit
so a big step on his part to say he
doesn't want to see those kind of quick
draws
in his tournament and now we see here
ocobian this position has been drawn for
a while folks
this looks like something you should
give up on but he has not
he's taken that kind of lesson to heart
and he's fought all the way
testing young nareditsky and it looks
like the youngster is going to pass a
test
and we're going to see one of the
fighting draws in the tournament back to
you jenin yaz
i still remember that story of alexander
shaballah and nakobian getting rewarded
for their fighting spirit
and it was uh distressing
because i was there in seattle being one
of the organizers
and america's foundation for chess
really wanted
to give the the players the best
possible playing conditions and every
reason for playing for a victory
and so many games were drawn without a
fight
it was like well when are you guys going
to fight if not for the national
championship
so that was a very impactful statement
that eric made
uh at the closing ceremony that's right
fighting chess and i think
tess has gotten better since then but we
still had a long way to go absolutely
it's gotten more popular people fight
more
but you know you just get better
because we see some of the rewards that
you know it's it's a little bit more
glamorous it's more popular
and um we can step up even further we do
have an official result by the way in
the irena crush
game she has won her game oh wonderful
i'll bring that in i was just going to
say we're
i think we're about ready to go into a
new era the magnus carlson
era and we see that in magnus world
champion
he does fight to the last drop and
also hikaru nakamura he's basically
saying i like magnus's approach
i have the same approach and you're
seeing from vessel and topolof
magnus ikaru these are guys who are
saying
well let's just play to the very end and
so
different era that's right and we're
getting our defending champion irena
crash
set up for her post game interview and
do we have any moves
in this um espra run game this
fascinating end game which could be
really the most fun of the round
ultimately who would have expected that
well after g4 uh we're in that situation
where
we think that black is just setting up
for that
uh eventually g3 um
moving her kingside pawn so looks to me
that
victoria is losing well we'll see if she
comes up with any defensive strategies
here
and right now we've got our defending
champion grandmaster irina crush
and she is with maurice ashley not just
defending champion
five-time champion grand master arena
crush first of all
thanks for being with us and
congratulations on your game thank you
maurice
now that game lasted a little bit longer
than we all anticipated
it seemed like you were rolling it up
and then she was rolling it back
yeah yeah it's good that i can still win
with an extra exchange
but no of course it was um it was a
little bit depressing
how long it took me to win this game and
you know at some point i was getting
lower on time i still wasn't making that
much progress
and so yeah i can't really be happy
about my technique in this game
do you feel it's because of her fighting
spirit your lack of form
combination well you know i played this
game quite okay
um i mean of course you know my opponent
did what she could
but um there's no reason when you're an
extra exchange to
let your opponent get back into the game
when it's an extra exchange for like
absolutely nothing
so um you know i think it's really uh to
my
credit that i made it so difficult for
myself you know
indeed there was this exciting moment in
the game when you played the move a5
and she played this move knight to b5 uh
you've you found a nice move here
yes i think queen b8 was actually the
best move of the game and here
i used my big time advantage to think
for 20 minutes
and make the probably the least obvious
move with the queen
because most obvious moves here are
queen b6 and queen a6
um queen b6 and queen i'm sorry queen c6
queen b6 or queen c6 but the
point is let me just show you the little
line so queen b6 let's say i do that and
you will see the difference compared to
the game queen b6
and um uh let's how do we do that
i think i messed it up oh because it
says receiving moves let's see if i can
get it right okay any variation
um now uh so i figured out what her plan
was in this position right so i was
thinking for a while so she was going to
go bishop
a3 and when i trade on c3
she's going to take with the knight and
here when i play
bishop a6 right there is the move queen
f2
not losing the exchange and the same
thing would happen if my queen was on c6
there's the move queen f3
indeed right so the thing is this is
actually looking pretty solid for white
with a knight on c3 you know you can't
push a4 so easily
i i mean of course black is probably
fine but actually i wasn't uh that
interested in playing this ends game
so the whole point of this move queen b8
was that after bishop a3 knight c3
knight c3 well actually this moment that
either she loses the exchange like she
did in the game which is a losing
position
where she has to play the move bc3 which
loosens her pawn structure and here i
was just planning to play the move
a4 with what i thought was like
which is the computer's first line oh
there you go computer likes it well yeah
i thought it was a big very big
advantage so basically queen b8 i
thought was the winning move in the game
and everything was going smoothly um
even
like the first part of my realization
technique was okay
you know i d5 trade the bishops don't
break up the pawn structure
you know constrain the night everything
was fine and then when i got the
absolutely winning position
which is time for white to resign that's
when i just
uh couldn't wrap it up so so what what
are your thoughts in a moment like that
are you frustrated are you thinking
what's wrong with me or or how do you
get out get those thoughts out your head
well um you know i was probably a little
bit upset that i was making it so
difficult for myself i mean
it's a little bit embarrassing really to
do that you know
you're worried about the crowd watching
going to happen if i don't win with an
extra exchange
how am i going to win this tournament if
i cannot win this type of position
so yeah that kind of thought crossed my
mind but i was just like well no this is
just not going to happen
you know so and you pulled it together
through
what were your thoughts while you were
watching uh
your main rival anna suffer in her game
she seemed to have a very difficult game
against uh irena zenya
yeah i think irena played the opening
quite well it was good opening choice
and i was spending a lot of time there
was one moment when white had traded
light squared bishops and i was looking
at her position i'm thinking
well what should white do rook d3 rook
d1 and
that's exactly what irena played rook d3
so she um
we had the same thought about that
moment um but yeah i think
that wasn't exactly the kind of position
you'd want to get
um really against anyone you know
because it was it was the worst for
black right and
i don't think she didn't have much
trouble making a draw right but
at least what i saw in the rook end game
no not in the right game
certainly fought really well uh so
you've won it's not anything unusual for
you to win a game in the championships
even even if you didn't
do it in a style you'd like to what are
your thoughts going into the following
games do you do you worry about the
future games or
did not playing perfectly the way you
want it to
affect uh how you think about the future
and no it doesn't uh it doesn't bother
me
this uh this last part of the game that
it took me so long to win
actually i think in the first round it's
good to have a fighting game
you know just when it's a total walk
over um
you know you're not it's harder to get
into the tournament so
i think if i would have won this game
with like no fight at all which you know
it could have been
um that maybe that wouldn't have been
the best thing from the point of view of
just feeling the pressure being able to
deal with it
um being ready to fight over the board
you know
i think this was fine it's a decent
entry into the tournament
one last question you came into this
tournament for the very first time i
believe as an 11 year old
now we have we see this 13 year old well
maybe an old lady by those standards
uh playing and acquitting herself quite
well what are your thoughts about
uh young ash rita she plays in her first
championship
right well actually you know i'm not
that familiar with the sharitas
games um because yeah they're just not
that many of them in the day
i tried to find some games you know so i
could prepare a little bit but um
i'm playing her tomorrow actually um
well what can i say i mean i think you
just uh take your chances don't be
afraid of anyone that's what i would
tell
her as a young as a young player here
you know i don't remember myself too
much when i was 11 right of so long ago
that
honestly like i don't know what i was
thinking back then in my first
championship i got two and a half points
out of nine
so it wasn't a great debut but um
it wasn't awful you know i scored some
points i i fought the whole tournament
so i think if she can do that that'll be
a great start indeed well if she can
replicate what you've done over the
championship
she's got a great record to look forward
to congratulations on your win and good
luck in the rest of your game thank you
maurice
with grand master arena crush after a
not so crushing victory
but she'll take the point back to you
jenna yes
thanks guys i know exactly where arena
is coming from you have these beautiful
games
you have nice advantage you're winning
you're winning and then you kind of go
into a
brain freeze and for the next 20 moves
you
don't make progress and you get so
frustrated with yourself
and you start using time and your
self-doubts creep in
but she rescued it when she needed to
and she played the right moves and got
the victory and that's
the result that she needed well let's
take a look at uh
sr ron yes i need his opponent tomorrow
so that should be fun
right uh so it seemed that um
instead of going for the lines where it
looked like
she was losing everywhere victoria has
uh
found some defensive resources here
which make it a little less easy and she
played this move rick a3 kind of trying
to
stave off the quick g3 h3 ideas
right okay so just to go back to recap
for a moment
we were back here and we were thinking
that
in case she victoria had played rook
takes a2
this was actually a trap that had been
nicely set for her and black would have
won
by capturing the rook and playing the
move bishop c4
with this threat of mate victoria saw
that
probably at the last moment right oops
probably at the last moment she saw that
just going to go back a few minutes
and played the move rook a3 and we've
seen back and forth the last two moves
so i'm guessing that victoria
well wait a minute what's going on here
what is going on here jen ah it still
works i beg your pardon rook takes a2
g3 it still works if king g1
and if king h3 uh
bishop takes a2 is the wind that we've
seen
so this is why we're saying king jif
a3 so now
what exactly let's see what happens if
g3 check because it's a fourth new one
if g3 check um
i don't see any better move than king
um h3o here is it
so the problem here for black is that um
bishop b4 doesn't actually threaten
checkmate
right pardon me what doesn't threaten
checkmate
bishop e4 or your bishop c4 does
it does but there is this check
i gotta believe black's just winning
here by the way
i mean it just it feels like this is
just one bishop c4 allows rook a5 check
um i'm thinking
maybe i could just go king g5
by the way something like king g5
what can white do exactly you still
can't now you're trying to you're going
to try to go bishops before check in a
situation where you can play king f4
exactly i'm aspiring for king f4
maybe even with a g3 g2 at a certain
moment as well but
first of all what does white do after
king g5 that's not even clear to me
do you go back with the rook rook a5
yeah and your idea of g2 is is uh
pretty compelling isn't it yeah i mean i
guess king h2 is in there
right and then just something like king
f4
um yeah we're always waiting first in
all these variations yeah
even though i'm uh i've got to be
careful that i don't allow
the queen to be just one of those uh
excuse me just
just pay attention to that but at the
moment there is
exactly and i guess
rook a3 i don't see a better move there
this is a very confusing ending
definitely a brutal defensive task for
me i'm kind of
impressed by how cool and calm and
collected she is and we've got uh
maurice ashley with some thoughts on
this yeah confused and
definitely a confusing ending uh i
looked at it
more intensely with houdini and it had
some fine points
to point out i might add that's like oh
let's think about that
in this position here after king h3
which is now on the board guess what
black has a fascinating try the move
e5 considered the best move in the
position
this move e5 being able to get down the
board if you take
on e5 now then the incredible
what looks like you should be playing
bishop to e6 check right that's what you
think would be the point
no the point is to play the move bishop
to c4
threatening made in one and houdini's
saying it's made in 14
it's over why the pawn is on e5 just to
stop
the rook from checking the black king
that was the only point of the move
after this move bishop to c4 bishop to
c4 threatening this check
is lights out what can you do if you
back up king g2
trying to deal with that suddenly king
g4 and the bishop stops a check
on the the lateral side here on the uh
the fourth rank and here come the pawns
storming down the board it's lights out
nothing to do in this position now it's
saying it's it's only made in ten
you're dead okay so this move e5
after king h3 is a really tricky shot
and white has to find the only move to
save herself
the move b7 deflecting the bishop and
after bishop takes
rook takes on a2 and now the bishop no
longer has
a long diagonal to use it has to use
this check
and then white can save herself here by
taking
on e5 and after check backing up and now
this rook is ready to sacrifice for any
pawn
that shows up on the second rank and the
game will end up in a draw no matter
what whoa
that's precise but she has to find the
moves will victoria find the right move
in this position
first of all will will the youngster
find the move e5
it looks like she hasn't she's played
the move king g5 instead
and that move apparently is only drawing
so she's missed
this shot king g5 doesn't get the job
done
because of the move rook to a5 yes as we
talked about before
it looks like she has some fighting
chances but who knows anything could
happen
in this game still back to you jen and
yes wow i love it i love e5 especially
because we have the other blocking
tactic today rook f6 the fisher banco
game from
our puzzle of the day yeah it's not the
most typical
tactic or idea blocking and so it's nice
that we got that theme in
today e5 a beautiful move it is i love
it
and and just to defend the players uh a
bit
you know for the whole game essentially
this spawn on e6 has remained on e6
defending the bishop on d5 and for very
practical reasons black was happy to
have the pawn on e6
and at a certain moment you stop looking
at the
any ideas of e5 it just doesn't enter
your consciousness
but it is a beautiful variation
nonetheless that e5
would have been a game-winner and at the
moment we're seeing
uh a repetition this is really tough
those of you at home who have engines
running i mean you can't expect people
to see this after four hours like
sometimes they do but you can't expect
it as a rule that's what makes it
interesting
right sometimes they see brilliancies
and sometimes they miss them
and that keeps chess fun and a lot of
the times the really really brilliant
games i'm thinking of this game that
vladimir
kramnik managed to draw against peter
sfidler in the candidates world
championship candidates tournament with
rook f6
it was a brilliant defense but the
problem is it was a necessary defense
there was absolutely no other way of
drawing the game
except to find this extraordinary idea
and in this position it may be that
um surround will find the move e5
only because there's no other way of
winning the position
and we do have some a few more moves in
the game wonderful let's refresh this
okay i will
get our up-to-dated position and we do
have a repetition
what i've seen what we have seen okay so
what day five happened
right you keep playing more k5 it seems
like victoria is playing the repetition
more quickly than um and saguaro and so
is it is it too late though
has she made it too many times for her
to backtrack now no i think she can
still go for the e5
no because i think there's been one more
right now now it looks like victoria
has played um it looks like king g5 or
k5 has happened right
ah no you don't have that on your board
yet no i don't have that one on my board
as far as victoria is concerned she
realizes she doesn't have any winning
chances and
probably she's very fearful that um
she's losing g3 check has been played
okay i don't know exactly when that came
in
perhaps it came in here by the way
just a second i'll copy the i'll refresh
my window i still don't have the
move g3 hmm
let's see what we've got on the official
site on the
uh how about the webcam i see it from
the webcam i can see the players
it looks like king h5 has just been
played
yeah uh-huh do you want to want to just
like manually type in those moves so we
can analyze the game
yeah so we got g3 check king h3 king g5
okay rook a5 okay king h5
okay rook a3 yes king g5 rook a5
okay king h5 and this is the position
that we have on the board right now
all right so she could play
rook a3 i believe and klamath or
she could call the arbiter and say i
intend
to play the move rook a3 and i would
like to claim a three-move repetition i
think
she can do that um let's see
am i wrong well because the pawn's only
been on g3 since move 63.
so don't you need it one more time okay
king h3
oh right this is number one this is
number one so number one is after king
h3 and move 64.
right so you can see how good titled
players are
counting here not very good spoiler
alert
aye and this is number two you were
right you're right and but she actually
made the move without calling it orbit
over it looks like
oh then she played 68
that gives the um option back to swara
exactly so she actually that was bad
good rules
review that's right in order to make the
draw
you actually need to call the orbiter
over and tell them that you're about
four
you make your move now it's too late you
can't call the orbiter over now
right she has to she's forfeited the
opportunity to make a three-time
repetition claim
well whereas if it's tomorrow now makes
king g5 it goes right back into her
right but a swarm could for example play
king g6
and there's no you know i'm i'm saying
and there's no
uh three-time repetition um
and again that's very important again to
play that winning move
right well the idea of e5
yeah not the winning move but the idea
of avoiding
a three-move repetition and again this
is very important
that you don't just execute the move on
the board and press your clock
because then your move is considered
over you have to
call the arbiter say i'm going to make a
claim
you write down the move you intend and
then the clock is stopped as the arbiter
confirms that a three-time repetition
occurred
i've been guilty on both sides by the
way
of doing it the wrong way also if you
make a
false claim of a three-time repetition
there's a very minor time penalty
infraction
either the arbiter will give your
opponent an extra few minutes or will
deduct a few minutes from your clock
and it's a very minor penalty so i've
always thought
that some grandmasters might want to
abuse the rule by claiming
a three-move repetition um
but it's not a big issue so another rule
is basically you know how to castle
know how to claim and draw these are
important basics will help you get
somebody actually asked about getting
into the u.s championship and how do
they do that that's one of the things
you you need to know the rules of chats
oh oh where are you guys
but um that is a test um that's actually
not just uh
now that st louis is a chess capital
that's not a test for the championship
that's a test to enter the city
you're just hassling when you land in
the airport well at the opening ceremony
we were told that there was going to be
a chess committee
you know the how did rex describe that
committee
oh test regulation the chess regulation
commission
exactly federal regulations and
standards
no traveling overseas without knowing
ambassador
well the more regulation the better
right right all right and we've actually
got a comment from
uh grand master maurice ashley about our
our final game here going on in round
one of the 24
u.s championship indeed jen
you know we're saying about the
youngster finding this idea of e5
it doesn't even win in fact the best
play
by her opponent will lead to a draw so
it's just
a fighting move we might dare call it a
fischer fighting move the kind of move
bobby fischer would
absolutely find and he would be
squeezing
blood from a stone as he was wanted to
do
the beauty of the idea as well is that
it's so deep there's so many
complications associated with it
even though conceptually it's just one
point that blocking
of the pieces remember this pawn move is
only meant to shelter this king
from this rook and it's doubly so after
the capture pawn takes pawn
to now expect her to find bishop c4
leaving the b-pawn free to rome allowing
also rook takes a2 in the position
by the way again with the b pawn free to
rome
no more mate on this side this bishop c1
a bishop f1
can be met by rogue g2 but the sweet
tactic after bishop takes
looks like the b-pawn is flying home
except oops
check come to papa and now bishop d5
check
that's that's a little bit much to
expect her to find especially the
position that's actually
drawn by best play so it's very logical
to see her try to repeat and just
and just draw the game no reason to play
and those that incredibly risky idea of
e5
but guess what she has found it it is
on the board she has played the move
e5 this youngster is
incredible showing her chops here
in the us championships very exciting so
esraren
has played e5 her opponent critically to
draw last move
wow this is this is an example i think
that a lot of coaches all across the
country are going to
show when they try to explain this role
because victoria really missed her
chance here to breathe a sigh of relief
um did victoria make him make a response
yet
after e5 oh it looks like she has
she took the pawn and bishop c4 was
quickly played
bishop to c4 was played with the mate
and one threat as vic
as maurice has been demonstrating
so now we're gonna see um
king g2 and it looks like victoria is in
deep time
trouble from the way she was moving the
pieces she's very very very nervous
so king did g2 and now we're expecting
them to just come in with the king and
she's done it she's doing the g4
she's bringing those pawns in for
the win oh my gosh oh my gosh and
maurice is going crazy over there he is
excited to see this young blood this is
like the um
oh my god a player who's
13 years old and it's her first
championship we see this player
she's looking to win the first one
absolutely why not
let's give it a shot play for the win
wow
really fantastic it will be really um
interesting to see it you know
did she realize it was a three-move
repetition certainly you might not have
noticed
um no a street that might not have
because
she seemed like she had a c5 idea on
mine well we'll just have to confirm it
ourselves to be doubly sure
okay so b7 on the board now right
but this is um uh eswaran's game to win
h4 h4 h3 check and get that
h-pawn going well it's removed you can
play h3 check right
nicely and then it doesn't matter king
g1
h2 jack that's the she's coming to h1
regardless
right h2 and king g2 and
now bishop d5 bishop d5 check
what she blew it what
no maurice was going nuts here
he's getting kind of upset uh i'm i'm
i'm we saw b seven uh so we've got
seven on the board we are expecting h3
but she didn't play h3 she played she
could have played bishop d5
check king g-1 bishop takes
and maurice was explaining in this
position when the rook is on the second
ring
you just sacrifice your rook uh for
the h pawn when it comes to h2 and
that's a draw
that's a and this is actually happening
oh oh
so h3 check was easy
but it was also with tempo right you're
advancing the pony tempo
yeah oh
boy she was on the edge of an absolute
brilliant win
wow we would have carried her out of the
tournament
all on our shoulders if she had won that
and palmer
so there was a two forcing possibilities
there's h3 check orbish of d5 check
and h3 check getting the pawn to eight
oh dear yeah
and she played a little quickly didn't
you she did i mean she only has
she only has a few minutes but still
when the position
when you're getting a 30 second
increment you need to make sure you know
which one to do
exactly and again we're just going to go
back on our board for a moment just to
show that winning moment and how close
it was
white had just played the move b7
and it's easy to get nervous about the
fact that this pawn is going to make a
queen
and that was why eswan played check
and quickly took the pawn if she got
nervous
had she stopped and give the stopped the
moment and given the position a little
bit of
thought she would have been able to play
h3 check
there's no no choice either the king
comes back to g
h1 or immediately in which case
the h-pawn still goes through with
check all the way and promotes
or after king g1 shag
and check winning as the h-pawn
queens with check so that was the
winning moment
right there
nervous is there some plane left in this
position let's take a look what do we
have
in our position right now and is there
any play
okay just a second let me get
the latest i believe we've got this as
our latest position we're thinking that
after i'm with maurice on this one
after we play king h king to g1 to stop
h2 white is prepared to sacrifice her
her rook at any single moment for that h
pawn and that's drawn okay
and there's no way we can ever play we
can never get a constellation with g2
and king g3 and because we're always
just going to be able to check us
on a3 well that you might have bishop f3
but i don't see exactly how you play
g2 without allowing king h2 then you
never get your king to g3
i'll just drop my rook over here to
a1 and maybe even the g1 i mean king
takes h3
easy draw easy draw that's just a
firm blockade for white
so last minute excitement as we
wind down round one a fighting round
it looked like it was going to be slow
play especially in the men's the open
but a number of decisive games and this
one
is one that slipped away yeah it seems
that way indeed and
it just shows the importance of you know
looking at a
you know she was so close she was really
and that was a moment where you really
want to be sure
you worked that hard yeah h3 track or
bishop
d5 check take a second which one's
better
exactly exactly boys talk about
snatching
a draw from the jaws of victory and
power to her
finding that move e5 was a thrill for us
i mean that just lit up our
our hearts i mean that such a young
player could find such a deep and
brilliant
move yes an incredibly talented player i
mean
even though she didn't manage to uh
finish it correctly it's still pretty
inspiring i think we're going to see
some good things from her in this torn
event
absolutely uh oh maurice is getting
himself excited again
because something else has got is
something
we might have a blunder alert indeed a
blunder alert has occurred
this is crazy that that idea was so
spectacular she missed
the win well guess what she has a win
again
that last move that was played rook to
c2
gets mated in 17. don't ask me let's
just go
to the tape the computer will tell you
she has this amazing move
bishop to e2 cutting off the rook from
the second rank
basic idea just cut it off more blocking
and now
white is desperate white has to try to
deal with this h2
threat that's coming at her and rook
check came back
and if she push it pushes h2 and after
king to g2 guys bishop f1 check
and if you go here simply king h3
and you're getting mated in the corner
that's sick the bishop is going to g2 to
mate
there are obviously other variations
we'll have to look at here let me first
turn this off but it all starts with
just this move bishop e2
a fantastic chance if you uh make a
casual move for example like e6
wondering what the threat is well then
here comes check and after the king
moves
just king marching down using the bishop
as a blockader so suddenly she has
another chance you see this g2 g1 mate
is coming i'm not sure what you could do
here maybe
king o king back no a rook back no
that's mate sorry
if you push the pawn
then simply check and here comes the
queen
that's all she wrote there so
here the critical moment bishop to e2
is playable and white simply
desperate what to do rook check king
back
there is no rook c4 check here comes
this check so it looks like this is the
only try
h2 check and again
king g2 you could play king h1 but this
line runs into simply
king 2 h3 and e7
runs into bishop f1 again all the lines
are the same if she finds bishop to e2
she's winning she's just cold-cut
winning again incredible turn of events
simple end games
never in chess that's what's so
beautiful about our game
it's never over until it's over you've
got to play moves
back to you jen and yes wow never
ever stop thinking even if there's very
few pieces in the board so let's see how
did that end up happening how did that
become a possibility
she played bishop you too fantastic now
how did that become a possibility
was white able to stop that i'm sure
yeah why you could have stopped that
with a well-timed chat correct
oops that is definitely not the game we
want to look at
no let's let's look at gray of kamsky
for the next
hour okay so let's just go back
we can watch the moves because they're
playing real quick but
they had reached this position and
we saw that one win already and now
we thought it was a draw and it looks
like this
move here rook c2 that was the
blunderful move
white had to make a different move uh
in this position rook c2
that was not it maybe king h1
not sure what she should have played
originally instead of putting the work
over oh maybe the rook shouldn't have
gone to d2 in the first place
yeah so all of this has been played
instead instead of c2 and
h two has victoria play king g2
um yeah we got uh right in this position
we've got
king g2 and then uh bishop to f1
has been playing so king g2 bishop f1
king h1 and king h3 are all on the board
the cool thing about this position
is that if it weren't for that pawn on
e6 what king's g3 would be
sailing end of the game oh so if only
she didn't have that pawn on e6 oh and
the game is over
victoria victoria has resigned it
appears exactly
oh my what a turn them around
and yes we've got the official result in
zero one for the youngster 13 years old
what a 83 move fight wow
that game was what six times longer than
the canopy grand game
ashrita ashrita eswara
a name we're going to be talking a lot
about in the years ahead
wow very impressive to pull this game
out when we thought that she was citing
fighting to save her life not to win the
game
and we are going to be sticking around
to try to
catch a word with this rahran and
let's let's uh hear from maurice ashley
now
you know we've been talking about the
bobby fischer prize and
uh those of us who poured through chess
history
remember bobby's historic
victories and particularly the game he
played
against donald byrne that was dubbed
the game of the century the moment it
was played well this game is not going
to remember
be remembered as such but bobby then was
all of 14 years old here's a young
lady playing in her first u.s
championship 13 years old playing
just in bobby's style we remember we
talked about this move rook f6
it was our position of the day to
analyze this blocking idea and we saw it
again and again
in homage to that great position and
that great player
so to see her play just scintillating
chess this
young lady is dangerous she has great
fighting spirit it's always the mark
of a champion when you see a young
player decide hey i'm fighting all the
way
no draw let's play the move e6 to e5
i don't want to draw i want to win
that's the style
we like to see and it's the mark of a
player who's got her sights on the
highest titles so congratulations to her
i look forward to interviewing her in a
few moments yeah very exciting i'd like
to hear from her you should ask if she
um if she knew that it was a three move
repetition because i feel like
she always she had this idea of e5 but
she kind of needed to analyze it
and she was trying to do the repetition
to save
to get there and to be sure to be sure
and maybe she overdid it maybe she
miscalculated that it was three times
right
okay sometimes it's confusing because
rook a3 was only played twice
but the first iteration was already on
a3
right so from earlier right right so
i think that sometimes it can be a
little confusing that's why
i don't know i have mixed feelings about
doing the repetition to save time
because
something like this could happen exactly
and i've seen that happen before it
happened to me
in a knockout the i had played against
bagan vaganzayev and i was easily
winning and i
made one repetition to gain time i
thought that was fine
and i made a second repetition just to
gain time
and that actually turned out to be a
third repetition
just like as we saw and he was very
quick johnny on the spot i'll take a
draw of mr smith yeah
victoria in this case she um she either
didn't realize or maybe she was just in
his own where you know a lot of times
they don't
do the official way they actually just
um
they instead of them they just kind of
shake hands maybe she kind of expected
that that's where everyone was going for
that and that
they she was going to play that move and
she was going to be like oh draw right
and
that happens a lot doesn't even
interfere
right so and we are getting our young
star
mic'd up as we speak right and then it
was that e5 move that just
go and victoria was not ready to
continue the game
so many exciting variations in this game
and in fact you can learn a lot about
tactics um just by studying it i mean
from the original
checkmating idea letting them queen and
playing bishop c 40 bishop
this is what we love to see and uh she's
here
eswaran ashrita winning her first ever
game
of the u.s women's chess championship at
just 13 years old
she's with maurice indeed we're with a
national master
ashritar swaron congratulations on your
game thank you
first game out of the gate in the u.s
championship how does it feel to win
it feels really great and i'm looking
forward to the future games
oh indeed this game we saw you were in
trouble
most of the game but you defended really
well until you got to a point where
it looked like you were basically equal
and then you got to this position
which we've been talking about where you
had this fantastic move e5
did you see it right away no not right
away like after i
repeated it twice but then i just try to
gain time so i can
because i didn't fully calculate it but
my time was going down so i just wanted
to get extra time
how much of it did you see from this
moment after e5 takes on e5 bishop c4
how much had you calculated did you
calculate all the way down or did you
just want this
this generally this position here we're
talking about after this
right at this point well actually she
played kg2 first
and kg4 and now and now at this point
have you calculated all this
yeah well did you know this position h3
was
winning actually h3 was the winning move
because bishop bishop d5 actually leads
to a draw
no no okay all right trust me we were
using the computer the whole time to
analyze so
we didn't see it either the fact that
you found e5 was already miraculous
uh how do you keep your composure at the
board you look so calm like
like nothing's happening you're playing
in the u.s championship for the first
time
i just tried to relax and think about
the position
and no matter what happens i just try to
do my best on my moves
where'd you learn that grown-up stuff
from
who's your coach by the way uh dion
boccika from bulgaria and the
norcal house of chess team okay so we've
got to give a shout out to them for
helping you
well your first game under the belt you
know we we
featured a position during our broadcast
that bobby fischer played
in the previous u.s championship against
powell benko do you know this game at
all you played rook f6
no okay we got to get her schooled on
that guys we got to get that one it's a
fantastic move where he made a blocking
move much like yours
and then we saw it pop up in your game
as well this idea of the double block
with the e5
and the bishop move uh absolutely
fantastic win on your part
now you get uh as your present arena
crush tomorrow
how does that feel i feel really excited
and
no matter what the result is i'll take
it as a learning experience
oh my goodness i this girl always says i
want to take her home
train i'll be the trainer wow
congratulations so we really appreciate
the young talent that you have and we
wish you the best in the rest of your
games thank you guys uh
we saw something today historic for sure
and expect a lot more from this young
lady in
this and future u.s championships back
to you i just wanted to break out into
applause after
that interview it's just wonderful yeah
if you're not smiling while you're
watching that interview
i mean forget it you're dead you just
said
you're ready to be buried no that is
really exceptional
and you know just applause applause just
really really sweet
well what a way to end a day one of the
us championships and u.s women's
championships here in the chess capital
of america
we are on again tomorrow at 12 55
central
standard time so a few minutes before
the game to give you our thoughts on
the pregame i expect it to be just as
exciting if not more than today
so don't miss a minute this is jennifer
shahadi and i'm signing off for grand
masters yasser sarawan and maurice
ashley
here at the chess club and scholastic
center of st louis
good night everyone
you